والسؤال الان هل انتخبه
الامريكان وهم يعرفون انهم
هكذا. اخطاء وعثرات وزلات بايدن
لا تنتهي. ولكن الامريكيين
النسيان. رجل الذي نسي زوجته
وظهر في مشهد وهو يسع مستخدما
كوفيد اذا? الرئيس الذي لا يعرف
ما هو اليوم الكبير فقال الخميس
كفه ثم صافح بكفه هذه الحاضر اين
ذهبت الاجراءات الوقائية واعراض
الجسدية فكل الطرق تؤدي الى رجل
يهرف بما لا يعرف. وهو كثير
يكمل ولايته الاولى بسبب صحته
العقلية او حتى بسبب صحته
وهذه زلة ايضا. فكم يحتاج
الامريكان من زلات رئيسهم حتى عن
مقصودا ام ان ما تحدث به اوباما
هو الواقع في كل الحالات سيتم
يحاصر بوتين كييف بالدبابات لكنه
لن يربح قلوب وارواح الايرانيين.
المقربون من اوباما قالوا انها
كانت في الواقع زلة لسان او مجرد
ومعرفة ما اذا كان مؤهلا للرئاسة
ام لا. بعد خمس سنوات من رحيله
عن البيت الابيض. عاد براك
اوباما لدعم بايدن في الترويج
للبلاد. وخلال الحملة الانتخابية
اتهم الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
بين رئيس يوصف بالجنون يقترب من
الشيخوخة والعجز اختار
بين كلمتي تصعيد وتطعيم. هل يعد
ارتباك بايدن الدائم الواقع الذي
انما باستقالته او بتقرير طبي
يظهر عجزه عن اكمال الولاية.
الامريكيون الخيار الاخير لان
الخيار الاول كان قد اصبح مجربا
تعشه من قبل. تلعثم بايدن اصبح
عاد حتى انه غطى في نومه خلال
وخلط بين اوكرانيا وافغانستان
والعراق وقبلها اخطأ في كتابة
تعيشه الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية? فهي تعيش تخبطا لم
عيد المرأة العالمي. واثناء
الفعالية اراد بايدن توجيه الشكر
كادت زلة بايدن ان تشعلها. وعن
اوكرانيا ايضا بايدن يقول ربما
الجميع حتى اقرب مستشاريه. لكن
البيت الابيض لم يتأخر في
الى وزير الدفاع الذي كان واقفا
الى جانب الرئيس. لكنه تلعثم
لم يطرأ اي تغير في هذا الموقف.
فارسال الجنود الى اوكرانيا يعني
بان جو بايدن لا يمتلك القدرة
الادراكية ليكون القائد العام
ام انه دمية بيد اشخاص من الحزب
الديموقراطي. في عبارة خرجت على
فتحت الكثير من التساؤلات. حينها
تدخل البيت الابيض سريعا واكد ان
اشعال فتيل الحرب ضد روسيا. وهي
الحرب العالمية الثالثة التي
الولايات المتحدة لن ترسل اي
قوات امريكية الى اوكرانيا وانه
عالمية عندما اخبر جنوده الذين
في بولندا انهم ذاهبون الى
تغيير النظام في روسيا. وهنا كاد
بايدن ان يتسبب باشعال حرب
بايدن منصب نائب الرئيس في عهد
اوباما لكن هل كان ذلك خطأ
اعتباره زلة لسان. بايدن والحرب
الاوكرانية. ظل بايدن يردد ان
حينها حتى اعلنت موسكو الحرب على
اوكرانيا فعلا. وخلال الحرب تدخل
وقت ليس ببعيد. طبيب البيت
الابيض السابق روني جاكسون مقتنع
قيادتهم. قبل ذلك خلال مقابلة
لبايدن مع قناة ام بي سي اخطأ
اوكرانيا لكن الاعلام الامريكي
يقول بانها زلة لسان. زلة لسان
اصبحوا ينتظرون اليوم الذي تنتهي
فيه ولايته وليس بانتهاء المدة
الكبير بدلا عن الثلاثاء الكبير.
فكيف سيقضي ما تبقى من رئاسته
خطأ ولم تكن هذه الطريقة التي
يعتزم بها اوباما بدء كلمته وشغل
روسيا على ان تغزو اوكرانيا في
اغلب تصريحاته رغم النفي الروسي
التدخل. واوضح بعد دقائق من
الخطاب ان بايدن لم يدعو الى
منافسه بايدن بالخرف مطالبا اياه
اختبار لتقييم قواه العقلية
لاصلاح قانون الرعاية الصحية بدأ
اوباما كلمته قائلا نائب الرئيس
احد الاجتماعات الرسمية رجل الذي
يقترب من عامه الثمانين وربما لن
اسم الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين كما كاد يخطئ خلال الخطاب
بحق الله. لا يمكن لهذا الرجل ان
يبقى في السلطة. كلمته هذه فاجأت
بايدن في خصوصيات الشعب الروسي
بقوله في كلمة مرتجلة عن بوتين.
لحظة كوميدية مكتوبة.
بايدن لكنه سرعان ما تدارك
الموقف وحاول استغلالها على انها
كلمة لمتابعة مستجدات تطعيمه
بلقاح كورونا قال اخذنا انا
الانتخابات الرئاسية الاخيرة بين
المتهور ترامب والعجوز بايدن ما
وبدا كانه نسي اسمه. في امريكا
كان الشعب هناك بين خيارين خلال
الشيوخ في ولاية وهذه حفيدة
ناتالي. بايدن اخطأ في وصف ابنه
والرئيس هاريس جولة افتراضية
لموقع التطعيم في اريزونا. منذ
لسان بايدن وصف فيها نائبته كمال
هاريس بالرئيس.
من قبل. لكن هل جو بايدن هو
الرئيس الفعلي للولايات المتحدة
الذي كسر قدمه يا ترى? هل لي
الرياح ايضا? لماذا كل هذا
بقدم مكسورة. بالمرة الاولى قالت
حاشيته انه سقط بسبب الرياح. فما
المتوفاة بانه كان عن ولاية
ديلاور بما انه في الواقع كان
مدعيا عاما للولاية قبل ان
يتدارك خطأ اخر بانه كان ممسكا
تنظر. لقد فهمت الخطأ. هذه
ناتالي هذه ابنة بو. عثرات
ونسيانه لا ينتهيان. فقد نسي اسم
وزير دفاعه خلال خطابه بمناسبة
بكتفي فينيجان ابنة بايدن يقوم
بالامساك بكتف ناتالي ويقول لا
ثلاث مرات تباعا. ربما كانت زلة
قدم. ظهر بعدها جو بايدن ولكن
مرة ثالثة. ما هذا الذي يجري عن
اي كبوة نتحدث. لقد سقط الرجل
التجني على الرياح? رد رسمي يقول
ان بايدن كسر قدمه اثناء لعبه مع
وقال هذا ابني بو بايدن. الذي
ساعده الكثير منكم في مجلس
قدم جو بايدن عائلته امام
الجمهور وامسك بنتالي بو بايدن
كلبه. لنتجاوز ذلك يا سادة. في
يوم الانتخابات الامريكية حين
بايدن يعاني من الشيخوخة. تعثر
بايدن. صعد بايدن سلم الطائرة
العسكرية للتغطية على ما يحدث
لكن الامر صار واضحا للعيان.
جدوى مساعديه ما الذي علينا
فعله؟ لا يا رجل، اليس من
المفترض بهم ان يطرحوا عليك هذا
السؤال؟ وليس العكس. اوالست
يدري ما الذي عليه فعله يدور
يمينا وشمالا الى الخلف. لكن دون
القائد؟ حاول المساعدون تدارك
الموقف واذاعوا الموسيقى
الموقف حتى ان السعوديين انتجوا
مشهدا تمثيليا طريفا للسخرية من
مرة اخرى. قهوة ونهض سريعا
مستعينا بجدار السلم. لكنه سقط
لقد تعثر. هيا انهض يا رجل. فلكل
جواد كبوة. نعم لقد نهض لكنه سقط
ليست المرة الاولى ولن تكون
الاخيرة فقد كثرت المماثلة لهذا
بايدن وحقق هذا المشهد ملايين
المشاهدات حول العالم. بل ان
الفيديو لقي رواجا كبيرا لدى
الامريكيين انفسهم. ذات المشهد
يتكرر فها هو بايدن يكمل خطابه
في مؤتمر صحفي. ثم يرتبك ولا
اكمل جو بايدن حديثه ثم استدار
رويدا رويدا الى الخلف. وخلال
بكل شموخ. حاول ان يسرع من
خطواته ليثبت لياقة. لكن للاسف
ذلك ظل يصافح الهواء وكان يتخبط
لايجاد مخرج المكان الذي هو فيه
الحال مع الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن. زلاته وسقطاته المتكررة
رئيس امريكي سنا في التاريخ.
وكذلك قدرته على ادارة الامور في
تفتح باب التساؤلات حول الحالة
الصحية واللياقة الذهنية لاكبر
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية.
الرئيس المضطرب. في احد خطاباته.
يا بايدن مع اول اخطائه? قالوا
انها لسان تكرر الامر عديد
المرات فاصبح العالم يقول انه
مصاب بالزهايمر. وهل يقود امريكا
سيصافح شخصا اخر? لكن لا. انه
يصافح الهواء. ما هذا الذي تفعله
الوقت. هل يتحدث الى احدهم? لا.
لاحظوا جيدا لقد رفع يده. هل
المثل القديم. لكن ماذا لو زل
الشخص في كلتا الحالتين? هذا هو
من هو مصاب بمرض كهذا? زلة القدم
اسلم من زلة اللسان. هكذا يقول
الزلتين. فهو يقع في كلتيهما بل
ويتعداهما لما هو اصعب. ها هو
يتلعثم بالكلام ويسأل مرافقيه ما
الذي عليه ان يقول او يفعل. رجل
الحرب العالمية الثالثة وزلة
قدمه اسقطت هيبة امريكا بحقك ما
سيواجهون حالا كهذا?
الذي تفعله يا رجل? انهى خطابه?
استدار الى الوراء. وقف لبعض
سبعيني هل هو كبر السن واعراضه
اذا ام ماذا زلة لسانه كادت تشعل
يتعثر ويخطئ في اسماء الدول
والرؤساء. ينام في اجتماعات مهمة
زلة قدم اسلم من زلة لسان. لكن
مع هذا الشخص ليس هناك فرق بين